let's go let's go welcome back to the
edge with your boy Michael Parson live
in your Bleacher Report app as always
drop any questions and comments in the
chat and I'll respond during and after
the show let's get ready to it played on
Thursday big Thursday night game um I
always love a Thursday night game
because you get the whole weekend uh you
get Friday Saturday Sunday the rest
recover and then you still go into your
original week so you get a very long
weekend it's almost like a mini by week
so Thursday games is always feel fresh
you feel great
uh especially going into the big games
that we have uh this week so it's going
to be a good one Seahawks Cowboys great
game Thursday night most viewed game
ever uh 15 million over 15 million
viewers uh battle uh Gino at uh Gino
came to play uh that was a very tough
game Gino came out there striking uh DK
too I mean DK had this sign language
celebration I mean this was I mean by
like this was I'm not even going to lie
this might have been top five
celebrations uh this year without a
doubt um definitely different uh the
creativity I mean everything he put into
that was super dope about it um everyone
want to know about this tweet that I put
out um and when I
say uh and and I said I really don't see
no team players the same watch any game
uh any film or any game is sad when I
say that is when you play the Cowboys
it's like the Super Bowl but it's not
even just that right you watch film you
get you got watch one uh from the last
we're in week 12 13 you watch the first
12 11 weeks of film and then you go and
watch our game it's completely different
game plans completely different uh
strategies uh they they go away from
everything they've been doing so it's
always harder uh in game adjustments and
things like that because of what we're
seeing and things like that and it's
always quite frustrating especially as a
player you're thinking hey I got to bite
on this team and you know obviously
that's part of the competitive Spirit um
but it's is it just sucks when you don't
have the expectations that you're going
to have and the competiveness in the
drive and what you want to do
accomplishing the game that's all I
meant by nothing personal um we still
won still had a great game but it was
just that greatness aspect that uh
myself and I know my team wanted to
reach and it just wasn't it just wasn't
a perfect game it could have been better
um but you know my guy Dak Prescott had
another amazing game 29 for 41 299 yards
three touchdowns zero
interceptions and this what leads me
into my MVP conversation I kind of hit
on it last week but we're going to go
we're going to we're going to go from my
my top five right now um and this time
we're going to go on order and with mine
this is not a QB based award for me this
is the most valuable player um this is
the most valuable player award you know
I think with MVP and things like this
that it should not matter if you're a QB
a defensive player or a non whatever a
non QB this is not a QB award as much as
we want to paint this picture uh and the
wards are so one-sided and uh they're so
determined on who they want to give it
to because QB does have a lot of value
in a position and I don't want to take
that away from them um your QB really
can determine if you win games or not um
but there's one there's just this one
guy right that just
is he's he defies physics right um I
don't I think he might need weekly drug
tests uh I don't know but this guy right
here he's
been above and beyond for his team this
year I mean he he he's
taking screens for 60 and 70 yards like
he is going absolutely berserk I mean
this guy he he has to
be and if he breaks this record right if
he breaks this record this is the going
to be the first time in NFL like that
has to be credited for something like I
mean
bro we going to get into it uh five
right now for
me
uh number
five
and and this is tough uh number five
I'mma definitely have to go with
uh I'm about to go
with Lamar Jackson number five for me
would be Lamar Jackson uh number
four
uh number four I'mma go with Tua number
four we're going to go with
Tua uh number
three
actually actually I'm not even going to
number four with tu I'm not even gonna
go number four with to I'm have to go
with Tyreek I have to go with Tyreek I'm
I'm might have to go with
Tyreek number three for me will be Brock
pie
um number
two will be Jaylen Herz and number one
will be Dak
Prescott um easy this is the top five in
order I know it's a Q and I did it and I
did this because I know it's a QB based
Award right um so that's why Tyreek
didn't make my top
three and he's just an outlier but
Tyreek is easily in the top three if not
number one and I don't want to just say
it's Dak Prescott because I think Tyreek
if he breaks this record right if he
breaks This Record he has to be MVP
but Dak he is the best quarterback in
NFL right now it's a QB award
uh he will be MVP most likely and Tyreek
will end up being offensive player of
the
year but if if they do give it to Ty if
they do give it to a non football player
and Tyreek Hill breaks his record he
goes over 2,000 yards he will be he
should be MVP he should be
MVP uh without without a without a
doubt he should be MVP I mean look at
this he's on Pace for 2100 yards and I
want to another person I want to give a
big shout out to is my guy Mike Evans
he's up there on the wall today if you
see who's on the wall I mean bro over 10
10 straight Seasons with over a th
yards 10 straight Seasons with over a th
yards bro this
is he's only one less than Mike Evans I
mean he's only one less than Jerry Rice
Jerry Rice has 11 Seasons with a th000
yards but he's the first player to 10
straight Seasons with a thousand yards
this is legendary he's a Hall of Famer I
want to he doesn't get his credit enough
because and I actually saw a stat today
I can't remember all the quarterbacks
yet he did this with seven different
quarterbacks that was a crazy stat Mike
Evans did that with seven different
quarterbacks Mike Evans you're a legend
we appreciate what you've done for the
game you don't get your flowers enough
but I appreciate you and what you do for
a game and yes you beat me a couple
times it's been a hell of a war I
actually want to tell you a crazy story
about Mike Evans um and this was my
first time meeting him I was actually in
college and I see Mike Evans uh he might
have been walking out a restaurant or
something like that and Mike Evans had
no idea who I
was um and I go up to Mike Evans and he
could he could tell you the truth about
this story I go up to Mike Evans and I'm
just like yo you don't know who I am but
I'm coming in league and it was just
like I and I think I was in Miami um
maybe right after the draft and he was
there um and I was like you don't know
who I am but you GNA see my time coming
I and I went back to him when we played
on that one game and I was like hey man
I told you I was going to be here one
day and uh you know I always thought
that was pretty dope because he still
sat there and talked to me and he had no
idea who I was or who I was going to be
and stuff like that so I always tell you
Mike Evans is like one of the dopest
people um
he's one of the dopest people I ever met
like kind-hearted genuine dude great
dude for
sure um and and there and there is some
debate right they talk about but besides
that let's they talk about the debate
with pie and uh Dak and and
jayen when you look at the scheme of
things and you look at you know what
part is doing PR is playing great
football for a second year QB regardless
I think but the thing about it I think
his Playmakers are just making better
plays um if you see Debo's
runs those are quick passes yes he's
getting to him but honestly sometimes
truth are be about or not and I am
talking crazy right now I am talking
crazy right
now and I'm and I'm talking very
crazy
I truly believe I could be Tyreek Hill's
quarterback yeah I could throw it up to
Tyreek Hill I could throw a screen pass
to
Debo like and this might be the crazy
Madden side of me but these players are
just that good Christian mcaffry is just
that good if I get get the ball out to
Chris mcaffry in space he's gonna make
someone Miss he's going to make a play
happen for me same thing with Debo auk
KD they're great playm if you watch that
game they were able to make people's
Miss and
obviously make big plays off of it small
pass precisive passes um kept in front
of him you look at this this the pass
chart
right those those aren't hard passes
they're good passes but those players
are really freaking good at what they do
they're some of the best uh each player
is top five uh at their at their uh
position um but they're just super good
um and and and that's just what they do
so that's my MVP debate I already gave
y'all my focal point on Tyreek Hill uh
tiger Hill will be the offensive player
of the year um but if he breaks that
record he should be the MVP without a
doubt um and and that's just no doubt
about
it I I look at this crazy set right Tek
has more receiving yards than every
Cardinals receiver every Patriots
receiver every Giants receiver jet wide
receiver and Falcons wide receiver that
is an insane
stat that's an insane
stat like I don't even think people are
realizing how crazy of a stat that is
that one man is accomplishing Tyreek
keep doing what you're doing just don't
do that on Christmas Day I'mma see you
then cheetah you know you my dog for
real I'mma see you on Christmas day just
don't do that stuff against me I'm not
trying to be chasing you all up down the
field and that's a fact so but anyway
the conversation over let's get into a
guy that I told y'all not to WR off and
he's had two huge wins in pretty much
back toback
weeks and and and this guy a lot of
people say we need to move on um they
and I want to I don't know if we bring
it up I want to see I want to show y'all
his stats prior to this when everyone's
throwing them in the dirt everyone was
throwing them in the shame um but if we
don't have his stats right look at
this y said the first two games he was 6
t0 Inception last four games he was four
TD seven interception a lot of people
say we should move on from Jordan love
we shouldn't do this we shouldn't do
that right and and this is where I
always try to get on you guys about it
and I say this is completely wrong we
should not be doing this to Young
quarterbacks who are still progressing
in the league we we're doing that with
Bryce young we're doing that with Jordan
love um and and we do what and that's
our common thing we're like oh they're
not playing well we do it with Zack
Wilson they're not playing well let's
get rid of them we got to find a new guy
in reality you need to stick with these
guys you need to build confidence in
them it does not come easy right it does
not come easy Jordan love just beat they
were the number two c uh Lions he just
be he just beat a the be people will say
he's one of the best teams in the NFL
and that's the Chiefs uh he beat Patrick
Mahomes on prime time and that's pretty
freaking hard to do he beat Patrick
Mahomes on Prime Time and this is why I
say you shouldn't give up his last three
games 857 passing yards eight touchdowns
and zero interceptions this is what it
means when your quarterback is building
confidence and people say he's looking
like Rogers no he's looking like Jay
love that studied Rogers who played
under Rogers he was he's he's starting
to get that experience you guys have to
realize Jordan love didn't play a lot of
football he got scrap up minutes behind
Aaron Rodgers so the first four years of
his career he never seen the
field Jordan love has the potential to
be the franchise quarterback for the
Packers for a very long time he is
playing Amazing ball couldn't be more
happy for him but this is why we
shouldn't as sham players for bad games
it happens this is the most competitive
sport in the world it is hard to win in
an NFL and it's even harder to stay and
be great and consistent in an
NFL Jordan love keep going let's stop
shaming and let's start building
confidence pick these people up pick
them up pick them up Jordan love keep
going brother that's just how you do it
keep keep turning the page keep turning
the page Matt M for is 16 and0 in the
month of December with the Packers
that's anane stat and this is where the
Packers rank in the NFC as we get closer
to the playoffs they're ranked seventh
in the playoff ranking right they're
ranked seventh with that record the
Packers have a chance to be
for uh I Hest say it would be
interesting if they're able to beat the
Lions and win out they might could they
could be end up being a fourth seed in
playoffs and that's a and that's a scary
sign because the Packers are a really
good team with a really good
coach it's gonna be very interesting to
see what this team does and the same
it's gonna be very interesting to see
how Jay love continues to perform in the
month of December and that's
championship football month championship
football month it'll be very fun to see
now the next quarterback I want to get
into is the Jets and the Zach Wilson
Saga there were reports this week that
the Jets want to go back to Zack Wilson
but he is reluctant my thoughts on the
situation
right
now a lot of you said y'all wanted to
get rid of Zack Wilson and y'all shamed
him and and I truly do believe Zack
Wilson was definitely reading the media
he got blamed by the media he got blamed
by
everyone when coach
said they they that was their best
option at quarterback right and you
thought anybody can just play
quarterback in the NFL because y'all
just think quarterback is just the
easiest job which is not and that's why
I do understand why the MVP um of the
league it's it's probably the hardest
position on
NFL without a
doubt but as fans right I'm a fan of the
game and I'm a fan of football uh I'm a
fan of the just everything about
football and obviously I'm blessed
enough to play and I'm best blessed
enough to play at the highest level so
understanding you're you're telling me
right you got some of the highest paid
athletes best athletes in the world all
scheming up to slow down another
team there's a lot of game plan there's
a lot of intelligent players
right
they're we do everything to slow down
this man right and this man has to do
everything in his power to make sure we
don't slow him down has his execution
been great no it hasn't and we're just
gonna be honest Zack Wilson's execution
hasn't been great but in reality he's a
good enough player to win games he has
won games and in some of the the hardest
league in the world
right Bryce young he's struggling to win
games it it's common like it's it's a
hard position to play and it takes a lot
of blame right if I go out and miss two
sacks or don't do no production and Dak
throws for 400 and maybe three picks and
we lose the
game no one cares about what I did and
and that's in reality and you can say
I'm one of the better players of the
Cowboys and I'm one of the bigger faces
of the Cowboys but in reality no one
cares what I did everyone cares about
what your quarterback did and if he
performed enough and B good enough to
win that is some of the hardest part
about football right and being a
quarterback especially and he's in New
York New York's huge in football they
love football uh New York media and you
guys deliberately and in
tempul killed this man's confidence y'
y' y y'all single-handed broke him down
and to the point where this man I don't
even know if he really wants to play
there anymore or if he feels he needs a
a new
start but it it's tough for him and I
and I get why he's like man I don't
think I can succeed on this team and
sometimes you can succeed on a team
right you see it between Kurt Cousins
how he was before and when he got to
Minnesota he started playing better it
sometimes it's just like that right but
this is what I would say if I'm Zach
right and you know this team may move on
from me um you have this narrative that
is painted against you and you have an
opportunity to fix it that's a bey thing
about life and if I are you I don't care
what no one says I don't care what no
one thinks I'mma go out here and just
play my brand of
football I'mma go out here and play my
brand of football and that's the best
thing you can do right because if you if
if I have five games left and I said
this is and and you almost have to put
this to the point where my life depends
on this right
your life depends on this this will
determine if you'll be in this the NFL
for years to come you have opportunity
not let your teammates down get better
and say I'm gonna play my D Brandon
football it doesn't matter if I win or
lose it doesn't matter I'mma just go out
here have fun and remember why I played
this game and then you're going to buy
yourself time to say I could go win on
another team I just can't win here and
people will respect that but you have to
give yourself that opportunity to say I
don't care what no one else thinks I'm
going to go play my brand of football
and be great and that's how I feel about
that Zach so if you hear me right now go
play your brand of football you only
have a little bit left you have four or
five games left play your brand of
football and just go shine man who cares
what people thinks go Shine Go
shine and that's how I feel about
it Colts uh quietly team seeking the
playoff race they're on a four game
winning streak
let's see Garner men you in the locker
room Garner's balling Garner's
balling Gardner is
balling I think a coast was a team that
people thought when Anthony Richardson
went
down they were going to go down but
Garner Mishu he's not Runing back
already he's not Runing back either
people should not sleep on Gardner Mishu
he is playing great
ball the coach defense is playing great
ball this is a team that people might be
worried about come playoff time they
might have to worry about the coach
especially with the Browns injuries and
uh the big loss they had we don't know
how to and they I don't know how long
Amar Cooper's out um and things like
that the Browns are still a really good
team but we don't know how that's going
to turn out let's see how they battle
this adversity but the Colt might be a
team that might be going like this and
they might surprise some teams come
playoff time especially because how the
afc's been playing we don't know how the
AFC is going to turn out a lot of teams
are 9 and3 7 and3 I mean nine and three
uh8 and
four uh and seven and five we do not
know how this going to turn out Miami
Dolphins are the number one seed right
now we do not know how this is going to
turn out a lot of teams been taking a
lot of
upsides Oo we don't know this is going
to be a very spicy side
very spicy but that's it for NFL I want
to get into the college football playoff
I kind of tweeted about this a little
bit the college football playoff teams
were announced on Sunday we got Michigan
Washington Texas and Alabama do you
believe FSU was snubbed and let's look
at Jordan Travis's
tweet devastated heartbroken and so much
disbelief right now I wish my leg broke
early in the season so y'all can see
this team is much more than the
quarterback I thought results matter
13-0 and this rers matches up across any
team and a top four rankings I am so
sorry gold
NOS that's what a QB and Captain looks
like
right that is that is and I do truly
believe they were
snubbed and and it sucks because Texas
they have a loss Alabama have a loss and
how they set the playoff they said each
team who wins their division and and
this is kind of how they said it at
first right each team that wins their
division so you got the
AC uh you got the ACC the SEC Big 10 uh
and whoever else right you already
know they never said it's
about who is who is they said the team
that wins their their side their
division and things like that then it
started to develop a little bit more
when Bama lost I remember when bner lost
and they were number one and they lost
and it was like no we're going with the
best teams we can't kick out B because
they're they're one of the best teams I
think it it's
a honestly this this list made it a
mockery of what college football is
Right th this made a fool out of the the
the people who chose the top four you
can say that FSU wasn't a top four team
right and then you could argue you can't
say that Georgia was in the top 14 I
understand this was one of the hardest
things to do but you cannot do that to a
group of
men and young men at that who are trying
to build this
sport this this was absolutely wrong
this should have not been
done and this is this is a mocker the
sport and this is why people are
starting not to take college football as
seriously because because of things like
this this this they shouldn't even have
allowed this
right it I feel bad for
FSU this this shouldn't have been done
to them and and that's complet 13 and 0
it's hard to do it's hard to win games
in college and they beat top matchups
they beat everything even without Travis
they are
winning it's
devastating it it's devastating and and
I argue for Georgia because I thought
Georgia played a good game they did
lose
um but I can't sit back and if you're
going off best teams right and and this
is the the controversy that I feel about
it right you don't put FSU in it right
because you
said they weren't one of the top four
teams can y'all honestly look in the
mirror and say that Georgia's not a top
four team
you're telling me all four of these
teams are better than the Georgia
Bulldogs right
now I I cannot agree with that I can't
agree with that I have to
like I
don't what they did this year makes no
sense no
sense they said do you think tcu's
performance in last year's National
Championship influence to leave FSU out
maybe but at the end of the day t you
deserve to be there Georgia was just
that dominant Georgia dominated everyone
in the same fashion we cannot make that
same comparison this is a different
group of men different
coaches you cannot compare last year to
this year that is completely wrong
completely wrong not justified at
all not justified at
all is you you just cannot justify that
if that's the case right you look at a
team like
Washington Washington has Elite Talent
but the Pack 12 really that do I'd
rather just wait and see and let's go
over how this how it breaks
down but I definitely think it'll be
Alabama or Michigan are going to win the
whole thing
Alabama or wishing win the whole
thing without a doubt but let's take
some final questions from the chat um
before we finish up
here so if it's the best teams or most
deserving I
believe it's not even about the most
deserving how I broke down originally
they said whoever wins their conference
right whoever was the winner of the SEC
the Big T ACC or whatever it was whoever
was the winner would move on to be in a
college football
playoff that's what they said and then
they started saying well it doesn't work
like that so we're going to do most
deserving cuz Penn State got snubbed the
same way
we we
were I remember saquon Barkley's year we
won the Big 10 Championship but we end
up going to the Rose Bowl because they
said we weren't one of the final best
four
teams they definitely have to fix their
ruling about what they want to put in
there and how they're going to do it
because this didn't make sense this year
it didn't make sense at
all it just didn't make sense how do you
leave CMC off the MVP list I you can
argue Christian mcaffrey as MVP for sure
but if you're going to choose and and I
and I did that strictly because it's a
QB based award but if you're going to
put one non QB player on there it has to
be Tyreek Hill it has to be um nothing
against Chris mcaffry he's having one of
the best years from running back over a
thousand yards leading league in
touchdowns
but Tyreek Hill is playing the best as
an N
QB without a
doubt if Debo helps perie and Hill helps
Tua cidd isn't helping Dak to be an MVP
convo too I'm not saying that as a
negative CD's have uh having amazing
year
right but you have to look at how
good what they comish right let's look
at CD's route tree and what he's doing
how he's scoring ing the way he's
getting open downfield versus Debo I saw
Debo last week take a screen pass for 40
plus
yards I saw him take a slant for 50 plus
yards and that all goes to QB passing
right I'm not taking away anything from
py he made the pass I'm not saying
that but when you have Elite skill
weapons who can take like Tyreek Hill I
seen him take screens for 60 I'm not
trying to take anything away from pie
I'm just saying when you have such elite
weapons all across the field players
that py has a top three tight
end auk
is I can't say top 10 but he's a really
really good receiver Debo Samuel he's a
he's a flex right he's a riding back
receiver whatever how you want to put it
he's a he's the he's the best flex in
the NFL Chris mcaffry is the best
running back in the
NFL and then you have great pieces
around it right Trump Williams best left
tackle but we're not getting into that
we're talking about
pure player and what they can
do it's not even arguable I mean they do
such great things when they get the bner
they just get him out in space and I
think
Kenan does a great job
coordinating they are
Elite so when you can do stuff like that
it takes away
right let's look at Tyreek Hill's
touchdowns I wish there was a stat when
it talks about yards of completed pass
versus and there's a stat what the
receiver does after he catches the
pass you you quite frankly find this
amazing what Tyreek Hill has been able
to do this year
he I
mean they're making the passes without a
doubt and that's why you can't take it
away from them but the skill players in
this league are just so much better now
they're so much
better um what about M Jones um Mac is a
little bit of a different story for me
right
I I'm a person who cares about
effort I do not think Matt Jones is
trying when I see him play I just don't
see the play
style
like it's one thing to struggle and
you're playing lights out and you're
doing everything you possibly can and
maybe you just might not be talented
enough maybe you just might not have the
speed the
talent
but if you watch him
play it's not as if he
is it's not like he has the same type
of confidence and play style as other
quarterbacks right when I see other QBs
throw a pick they Sprint trying to
tackle the defender M Jones just whips
like he's not looking for contact he
constantly has his head
down his body language is
bad and and it sucks because we' seen
him at Bama and he L he was a
winner he was a
winner so to see the M Jones at Bama to
now it does not look like the same
player and I know that it all doesn't
transition and he had amazing talent
around him at Bama
I'm not going to I'm not so I'm not
going to go about talent wise and things
like that but he had one of the great he
had the greatest college coach ever and
that's Sabin arguably one of the
greatest NFL coaches that's bich so it's
not really coaching it's it's a little
bit with the player the effort is not
there I think the potential is there for
sure and I'm not trying to discourage
him I just wish his effort was there you
could tell when someone's putting her
all in to it and it it just look like
he's giving up on his team
right it I don't really want to hit the
M Jones because if you watch the
tape he just
doesn't
look I just don't see that competitive
nature like that hunger he's not hungry
like you could just see like I just just
look what do you think about Jake
Browning last night I thought that was
crazy I thought he played amazing I I
just saw a stat too that he was one of
seven quarterbacks to have over
350 passing yards and with over 85%
completion rate when you when you if you
like I don't who had that the Bengals
going to go upset top seated
Jags on Monday Night Football that was
an amazing game top game Jake brownie
absolutely hooped absolutely hooped
did you seen Shawn McVey talk about his
fantasy team thoughts I think McVey was
joking around a little bit I don't think
he was too serious I thought he was just
messing around out of respect for their
field goal block operation we said let's
make sure we have great ball security
but if we can punch it in um you know
Karen's on my fantasy team it's a joke
it's a joke I don't really mean that all
right kidding I just think he's egging
on the fans a little bit um obviously
because y'all care about fantasy a
little bit uh so much and he's being
spicy but Jake brownie entered
conversation with Tom Brady pton Manning
Drew Brees Justin Herbert Lamar Jackson
like that is dope man Jake keep balling
way to step up for your team and one of
the biggest moments huge huge Joe Mixon
B out last
night man but preview of this Sunday I
know this is what y'all here for big
game Eagles Cowboys number one rivalry
in all of football doesn't matter where
you put it of course Shaq Leonard signed
with the Eagles yesterday um big signing
for them I mean I feel like they already
really had a good defense um you know
super talented you add him uh we don't
know how they're going to use him yet
but super dope um does this matchup have
MVP implications of course of course
they're always going to do big games uh
Jaylen Herbert's obviously a top three
quarterback at MVP r race Dak Prescott
you got two great quarterbacks two great
defenses it's going to be a great game
uh super excited it's going to come down
to execution and finishing uh so man
y'all know what to do Cowboy Nation see
y'all Sunday let's protect our land
we're America's team for a reason we
need everyone there sell it out pack it
out it's going to be one of the games of
the century can't wa DLC though you
already know Eagles Cowboys super
excited to perform in front of y'all and
I see y'all next week on the edge with
your boy Michael Parson's love I
appreciate y'all love y'all and see
y'all next
[Music]
week